many so-called religious believers
refused to just follow the direction of
the federal and state governments
medical experts and public health
experts yesterday and they filled
churches on what was Easter 2020 one
place where this was particularly
prevalent was the state of Kentucky and
the governor Andy Beshear a democratic
Kentucky governor important detail here
since it almost went the other way Andy
Beshear said if you go to church on
Easter you will have to quarantine for
14 days to prevent the church from
becoming the Nexus of one of these super
spreader events and it was announced
that police would be at churches
recording license plate numbers they
would be sending out potentially sending
out misdemeanor violation orders
violation of orders issued by state
health officials and would be forced to
self quarantine for 14 days now of
course folks like Republican Senator
Rand Paul don't like it who cares what
Rand Paul thinks he took a test for the
virus and then went to the Senate gym
while the test was being processed
ultimately coming out positive for
coronavirus so clearly Rand Paul is not
the person we should be listening to
this we have video of the parking lot
and as you can see if you're watching a
full parking lot filled with people and
cars just like nothing is going on
Kentucky State Police did show up and
put notices like this one on people's
cars saying that the cars presence in
the parking lot indicates the occupants
are at a mass gathering which is
currently banned for public health
reasons they are at risk of contracting
coronavirus and they are to self
quarantine for 14 days here is video of
police officers walking around placing
the notices on vehicles and of course
even media people at the church covering
this insanity ended up with those same
notices on their cars saying they needed
to self quarantine so do I love this no
do I want State Police having to do this
of course not public officials
health officials police officials
everyone's desperate so what do you do
when people believe going to church
protects them from coronavirus and you
immediately have all sorts of people
talking
about this is authoritarian this is a
nightmare this is like martial law
people aren't allowed to pray and all of
this different stuff come on guys come
on can't you for a second put aside that
ideology and realize we none of us like
this but we've got to work together
we're in this together and forcing
police to have to do stuff like this out
of desperation is what's wrong we have
people who either don't care or don't
believe it or can't understand what it
is that is going on remember the blood
of Jesus lady this is a woman who was
interviewed leaving her church in Ohio
it was maybe last week or the week
before remember what she had to say
driving out of this Ohio parking lot is
a woman who just attended a church
service with dozens of other people
including children can I ask you about
your decision to go to church to be
inside that building I wouldn't be
anywhere else aren't you concerned you
could in fact other people if you get
sick inside I'm covered in Jesus's blood
I'm covered in Jesus Church who you
might have know all of these people go
to this church but you're going to be in
the grocery store every day I'm in
Walmart thank you very much that is
weaponized malignant ignorant what do
you do with that and of course the
police I mean you know if you hand out
these mandatory quarantine things to
thousands of churchgoers the police
don't even have the resources to
actually verify that all of those people
are self quarantine they just don't so
it's not only Trump that is preventing
us from dealing with this as
expeditiously and efficiently as
possible it's also these folks I saw
video from Vancouver over the weekend of
so-called libertarians protesting the
lockdown by gathering on the streets
we're fighting the virus but meanwhile
they are fighting what they say are you
know authoritarian tactics to keep them
home some go even further saying there's
a consider a conspiracy to hurt the
economy on purpose merely to remove
Donald Trump so we're fighting the virus
which spreads virally we're also
fighting dissing from
and conspiracies and bad and/or ignorant
people all of whom seem to be virally
spreading their disinformation as well
we now heard from dr. foul Chi if we had
started earlier and taken this more
seriously and had a concerted lockdown
effort we would be much better off than
we are today this is the type of stuff
that I'm talking about